[Musique]
les chéris on est devant on est devant
le studio
regardez on abuse historique
[Applaudissements]
à l'essai
beaucoup de gens qui veulent faire ce
soir
les huit ans
m
[Applaudissements]
pour cela les soirées mousse ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais
m
[Musique]
vgi je voudrais expliquer quelque chose
je prends vers le gîte sous peu
la musique est ce qu'on peut enlever la
musique les chéris j'aimerais me dire
quelque chose
le grand patron téva ceara on voudrait
se réconcilier avec lui et lui dire
qu'on aime parce que lui tend c'est
grâce à lui aussi que tpm paix à 8 ans
donc merci à lui qui a lancé l'émission
sur direct 8
merci ara aprikian merci mon chéri tu
sais qu'on t'aime voilà et que c'est
grâce à toi aussi qu'on est là donc les
chéris au war est réconcilié avec eux on
va arriver et dans un instant de rennes
surprise pour eux puisqu'on aura le
totem de la réconciliation je vous
demander de bien vouloir venir avec moi
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va mais chéri certains les
chéris ça va les chéris merci d'être là
ça m'avait série
attendez attendez
attendez les chéris attendez attendez
attendez l'échelle est ce que vous êtes
content d'être là
[Applaudissements]
chez aux quatre petites secondes
je voudrais qu'on amène vrai qu'on amène
oui monsieur qu'est ce que chérie je
voudrais qu'on a mais
ça c'est la faute aux le placer l'oscar
de minutes les chéris apprenez à
connaître les chérit les chéris juste je
voulais un truc moi dans mon dos les
chéris djoudi en hommage en hommage
regardez regardez ce qui arrive c'est le
totem de 8 m pour la réconciliation
merci à mensah
[Applaudissements]
hollande est touchée avec des grands
patrons chez cette statue à défendre les
solides fondations
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réconciliation n'était pas scellé sa
revivre les scènes
à gaza
chante les abus
[Applaudissements]
je
lucas
soirée mousse au ghana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
conséquence
à
là
j'espère que tout ça va nous réconcilier
fin je vais vous dire que je vous aime
très très fort c'est sûr vous avez passé
une bonne sera avec nous et n'oubliez
pas la télé ce que tu as
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]